ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today we are discussing ways
to improve your fitness.
In particular we are
going to discuss tools
that you can incorporate
into your existing fitness
routine that will
allow you to make
significant improvement
without having
to invest a lot of extra time.
Most all of the tools we
are going to discuss today
were gleaned from the
6 episodes that we
did with Dr. Andy Galpin.
We provide a link to those
full episodes in the show note
captions, of course.
Now, those episodes
included a very large number
of protocols, everything from
how to build a fitness, routine
how to enhance recovery,
nutrition and supplementation,
exercises and routines
aimed specifically
at strength or
hypertrophy or endurance
or building anaerobic capacity.
What I've done is to select key
protocols from those episodes
that I myself have
started to incorporate
into my existing fitness
routine and that I
think will be especially
beneficial and frankly fun
for you to incorporate
into your fitness routine.
Now, a little bit
later in this episode,
I review the key components
of any fitness program, that
is the number and type of
cardiovascular training
sessions and resistance
training sessions
that are essential for
everyone to include
as a template or a foundation
for their overall fitness
program.
Now, a little bit
later in the episode,
I will be sure to
review what are
the essential components
of any fitness program,
so the number and type of
resistance training sessions,
the number and type of
cardiovascular training
sessions, as well as
some of the elements
of how those are
arranged to ensure
proper and adequate
recovery between sessions
so that you can continue
to make ongoing progress.
However, the bulk of
today's discussion
is going to focus on tools
that you can use again very
easily, very quickly, in
some cases even saving you
time during your
fitness regimen in order
to improve all aspects of
your fitness, your endurance,
your muscular endurance,
your anaerobic capacity,
your recovery, your
strength, your hypertrophy.
And in describing these tools
to improve your fitness,
it also provides an opportunity
for each and all of us
to step back from our
existing fitness routine
and ask whether or not
it's really checking off
all the boxes that
are necessary,
as well as where we can be
more economical with our time
and our efforts
in order to reach
our specific goals related
to exercise and performance.
So by the end of
today's episode,
you can be sure that
you have at least one
and as many as 12 tools
that you can incorporate
into your existing
fitness routine,
again, without adding much
additional time or effort that
are sure to accelerates
your progress.
Before we begin, I'd
like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford.
It is however part of
my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to
consumer information
about science and
science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with
that theme, I'd like
to thank the sponsors
of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is LMNT.
LMNT is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you need
and nothing you
don't, that means
plenty of salt, sodium,
magnesium, and potassium,
the electrolytes, but no sugar.
Having adequate
electrolytes is absolutely
critical to cellular function,
in particular the function
of neurons.
In order for your neurons
to function properly
you need electrolytes
in your system,
and you need to
be well hydrated.
There's a lot of research
to support the fact
that if you are even mildly
dehydrated, that your cognition
suffers, your physical
performance suffers,
and your sleep can also suffer.
So getting adequate electrolytes
and hydration is key,
and element allows
you to do that.
I typically mix LMNT into
16 to 32 ounces of water
and drink that first
thing in the morning.
I'll also drink another
one during exercise,
and sometimes another one after
exercise as well, especially
if I've been sweating a lot,
or it's a particularly hot day.
If you'd like to try
element, you can go
to drinklmnt.com/huberman,
and that's spelled
L-M-N-T.com/huberman.
And you can claim a free
sample pack with your purchase.
Again, that's drinklmnt,
L-M-N-T.com/huberman to claim
a free sample pack.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Helix Sleep.
Helix Sleep makes
mattresses and pillows
that are of the absolute
highest quality.
I've talked many times
before on this podcast
about the fact that
sleep is the foundation
of mental health, physical
health, and performance.
And I say that because
when we are not
sleeping well or enough,
all of those things suffer.
Conversely, when we are sleeping
well and we're sleeping enough,
all of those things improve.
One of the key elements to
getting a great night's sleep
is to have the proper mattress.
Helix mattresses are different
because they are customized
to your unique sleep needs.
So if you go to their website
and take a brief 2-minute quiz,
they will match you
to a mattress that's
ideal for your sleep needs.
The quiz asks questions
such as do you
sleep on your back, your
side, or your stomach?
Perhaps you don't
know, that's fine too.
Or do you tend to run hot
or cold during the night?
Things of that sort that
allow them to match you
to a mattress that will give
you the best possible night's
sleep.
I started sleeping on a Helix
mattress a few years ago
and it has vastly
improved my sleep.
If you're interested in
upgrading your mattress,
you can go to
helixsleep.com/huberman to take
that 2-minute sleep quiz,
and they'll match you
to a customized mattress.
You can also get up to $350
off any mattress order and two
free pillows.
Again if you're
interested, you can go
to helixsleep.com/hurberman
for up to $350 off and two free
pillows.
Let's talk about tools
to improve your fitness.
Before we do that,
however, I just
want to briefly
remind everybody what
constitutes a core or a
foundational fitness program.
Now, what I'm about
to describe is not
for the athlete that's
trying to just improve
one aspect of fitness
or sports performance.
So for instance, if
you are a powerlifter
and your main goal is
to move more weight
on the core
powerlifting movements,
or if you are somebody
training for a marathon,
it's likely that
your core fitness
program will differ
substantially from what
I'm about to describe.
However, the vast
majority of you
are almost certainly
trying to have some level
of cardiovascular fitness.
So the ability perhaps
to run a mile or more,
certainly to be able to
walk up a flight of stairs
without getting winded,
you almost certainly want
some degree of
strength, the ability
to perhaps pick up a
heavy load of groceries
and carry it in one arm
as you carry something
else in the other arm.
You want the ability
to help move furniture.
You want the ability certainly
to not injure yourself
when performing daily
tasks, and perhaps
you also want to be able
to go out and play a pickup
game of basketball or
soccer, or to go out
on a long hike with a family
without feeling so sore
that you have to rest
in bed the next day.
An optimal fitness
program of the sort
that was covered in the optimal
fitness protocols episode
that I did is therefore one
that checks off the major boxes
that science tells us are
important for health span
and for lifespan,
and that can also
help us improve various
aspects of performance,
and improve various
aspects of aesthetics,
whether it's fat loss or
muscle growth, if we choose.
So without going into that
program in a lot of detail,
the core elements
of it are that it
includes at least 150
minutes and ideally
more like 200 minutes per week
of so-called zone 2 cardio.
I'll talk a little
bit more about zone
2 cardio a little bit
later in the episode.
But zone 2 cardio is for,
those of you that don't know,
a type of
cardiovascular exercise
that you can do
while maintaining
a conversation
without getting winded
but that if you were to
push a little bit harder,
that you would find it hard
to complete your sentences.
In general, zone 2
cardio is the sort
that you can do while purely
nasal breathing, unless you
need to talk, of course,
it's perfectly fine
to talk while doing
zone 2 cardio.
And again the
scientific research
tells us that we should all be
getting at least 150 minutes
and probably more like 200
minutes of zone 2 cardio
per week.
Now, in addition to that, a
foundational or optimal fitness
program for most people is
going to include anywhere
from 2-4 cardiovascular
training sessions that
are separate-- that's right--
separate from the zone 2
cardio, as well as 2-4
resistance or strength
training, sometimes also aimed
at hypertrophy or muscle growth
training sessions.
Now, we have to acknowledge
that most people are probably
not going to hit the upper
threshold of all of those three
things.
Most people simply do not have
the time and/or discipline
to get 200 minutes of zone
2 cardio per week, plus four
resistance training
sessions, plus four
cardiovascular training sessions
that are separate from the zone
2 cardio.
As a consequence, the
optimal fitness program
that I described in that
episode, and by the way,
it's the program
that I've essentially
followed for the last
30 years or more,
includes three cardiovascular
training sessions.
So one of longer duration
sort of typical endurance type
training.
This would be a long, slow
jog or a long hike one
day per week, as well as a
shorter cardiovascular training
session of about 25 to 30
minutes moving a bit faster,
getting the heart
rate up a bit more,
breathing a little
bit harder, as well
as one very short cardiovascular
training session that
would fall under the category
of high-intensity interval
training, things like sprints,
which don't necessarily
have to be done running.
Could be done on a rower.
It could be done on
a bike, et cetera.
So three cardiovascular
training sessions, as well as
three resistance
training sessions.
I want to acknowledge that
resistance training can
be done with body weight.
It can be done with
weights, with machines.
I talked about the
differing virtues
of one approach versus
another, but nonetheless,
three resistance
training sessions.
One focusing specifically
on leg training.
One focused specifically
on torso training.
That's right, chest,
shoulders, and back altogether,
as well as some neck training
for important reasons
that were mentioned
in that episode.
And then a third
session that was
aimed at somewhat smaller body
parts, biceps, triceps, calves,
and some other small body
parts that tend to be neglected
and that are important to
train if one wants to encourage
muscular balance both
aesthetically and structurally
to avoid injury and
have excellent posture.
So those were the core elements
of that foundational fitness
program.
And I mentioned then
and I'll mention
again now that that
program is not a mandate.
It is not an absolute
requirement for anyone
to follow.
It was simply meant as a
template from which people
could evaluate their own
existing fitness program,
perhaps modify it
somewhat or a lot,
or if you were interested in
trying that specific fitness
program, that you could do that.
And we have provided a link
both to that episode in the show
note captions, but we've
also provided a link
to a table or chart
that describes
that foundational
fitness program.
It provides examples of
different cardiovascular
training and resistance
type training sessions.
And it describes some potential
exercises and the rationale
for those exercises,
and the rationale
for selecting particular
repetition ranges
and rest between sets.
All of that information is
available completely zero cost.
You don't even need to
sign up for anything.
You simply go to the link that
we provided in the show note
captions, and there's a
downloadable PDF there
for you to explore.
Now, in addition
to the solo episode
that I did about optimal
fitness protocols,
we did a six-episode
guest series
with Dr. Andy Galpin, who
is a professor of physiology
at Cal State Fullerton
and a world expert
in all aspects of exercise
and muscle physiology.
That episode described
a lot of the science,
and in particular
science-backed tools
for improving everything
from long-distance endurance
to anaerobic capacity, strength,
hypertrophy, speed, power,
recovery, nutrition,
supplementation, and ways
to develop a year-long
program that will
ensure you ongoing progress.
In that series, Dr.
Andy Galpin provided
an enormous amount of valuable
information, such that anyone
and everyone, meaning
the person who's
just interested in
starting a fitness program,
or improving their
existing fitness program,
or the elite athlete who
is interested in improving
their sprint times,
or their jump
height, or their powerlifting,
or their marathon time,
could clearly benefit from
some or all of the protocols
that he described.
Now, because that series is so
extensive in terms of its depth
and breadth, again, providing
so much value at 0 cost thanks
to Dr. Andy Galpin's
expertise, but at the same time
because it might be a little
bit intimidating for many people
out there to try and figure out
which protocols to incorporate
into their existing
fitness regimen,
I thought it would be fun
and very beneficial to talk
about some of the key
tools that were described
throughout that
series that one could
consider incorporating into
their existing fitness routine
now.
So that's what this
episode is really about.
It's about the tools
that I personally
gleaned from those
discussions and that I
found to be of tremendous
value in improving
both my cardiovascular
fitness, my strength
and hypertrophy
training, my recovery,
and other aspects of my
overall fitness protocols.
And when I say
beneficial, I mean
in terms of improving my
cardiovascular fitness,
improving my strength
and hypertrophy training,
and that have improved
the various metrics
of fitness lifespan
and health span which
include things like heart rate
variability, resting heart
rate, blood pressure, VO2 max,
as well as some of the fitness
metrics that were described
during that episode series
with Dr. Andy Galpin,
such as performance
metrics, the ability to
jump a certain distance,
the ability to run
a certain speed
or to run a certain
distance at a given speed,
the ability to move
weights in good form
for a certain number
of repetitions.
Again, all of the metrics
of performance and health
are going to vary tremendously
from person to person
depending on where
you're starting,
how long you've been
training, and other aspects
of your health.
The tools described
in today's episode
are designed for everybody.
Again, these are
simple tools that you
can put into your existing
routine that should really
move the needle forward
in terms of improving
your overall levels
of fitness and health.
OK, let's talk about the
tools to improve your fitness.
The first tool is to
mesh your zone 2 cardio
with your daily activities.
So for those of you
that don't know,
zone 2 cardio is
the type of movement
that we typically call
cardio exercise that
elevates your heart
rate somewhat,
increases your
breathing somewhat,
but that still allows
you to carry out
a conversation without having
to pause or to gasp in order
to complete your sentences.
OK.
So that's a general rule
of thumb for zone 2 cardio.
Now, for those of you that
use a fitness tracker,
you can monitor whether or not
you are in zone 2 cardio very
precisely.
But if you're like me and you
don't use a fitness tracker,
it's very easy to know if
you're in zone 2 cardio
because again, it's that
level of output that puts you
right below or somewhat
below the threshold where
if you were to exert yourself
with any more intensity,
that you wouldn't be able
to complete your sentences.
Now, this could, of
course, be evaluated
by jogging with someone or
walking with someone or hiking
with someone and carrying
out a conversation.
If somebody isn't available,
you could, of course,
do this by trying
to speak out loud
and have a conversation
with yourself,
or if you want another way
to monitor whether or not
you're in zone 2 cardio
without having to use a fitness
tracker, you could simply
ask yourself whether or not
you are maintaining a level
of output that increases
your heart rate
and your breathing
but that allows you to
maintain purely nasal breathing
the entire time.
Any of those approaches
will tell you more or less
whether or not you're
in zone 2 cardio.
Now, the scientific data
tell us that we should all
be getting anywhere from 150
minutes to 200 minutes per week
minimum of zone 2 cardio for
sake of cardiovascular health,
cerebrovascular health, and
a number of other aspects
of health that are important
essentially to everybody
for health span and life span
Now, many people
including myself, schedule
zone 2 cardio into their
weekly fitness regimen.
So for me, I have
one day a week.
For me it falls
on a Sunday where
I go out for a jog that lasts
anywhere from 60 minutes
to 90 minutes.
It's a slow jog.
I can maintain nasal
breathing the entire time
or have a conversation
with somebody else
or myself the entire
time if I like.
Or sometimes it
consists of a hike
by myself or with other people,
and sometimes those hikes
extend anywhere from
an hour to four hours
depending on the
circumstances, et cetera.
I will mention that
whenever possible, I try
and do that once a week zone
2 cardio session out of doors
because I like being in nature,
and I like getting sunlight,
and I like getting fresh air.
Now, during the discussion
with Dr. Andy Galpin,
I explained how I
get my zone 2 cardio.
And I acknowledged that
once-a-week session doesn't
always allow me to
reach that 150-minute
to 200-minute minimum threshold
of zone 2 cardio per week.
Sometimes it does,
sometimes it doesn't.
And his response to that
was very reassuring.
What he said was, look, if you
want to schedule zone 2 cardio
and head out for a long
Sunday jog or hike, terrific.
If you want to schedule a zone
2 cardio as two or more sessions
on the treadmill or
on the bike, great.
But that he doesn't
actually think of zone 2
cardio as exercise at all.
And to that I gasped, and then
I was a little bit deflated.
I thought, oh, great.
I've been doing all
this zone 2 cardio,
and you don't even
consider that exercise.
And then what he said
was very reassuring,
and I think it's going to be
very reassuring to all of you.
He said, first of
all, zone 2 cardio
is absolutely critical to our
health for a number of reasons
that I already mentioned.
But in addition to that, zone
2 cardio does not impede,
and in fact, can enhance our
other aspects of fitness.
So for example, our
strength training,
our hypertrophy training,
or any type of speed work,
or other types of cardiovascular
training one might do.
And that the best
way to get zone
2 cardio is OK, if you want
to schedule it, schedule it
as a session.
But that to simply increase
the amount of walking
and in particular, walking at
a rapid pace that one does,
and to increase the
total amount of movement
that one's getting
throughout the week.
So taking groceries in and
out of the grocery store,
running around with the kids,
taking a walk with a coworker
while having a work discussion,
taking your calls for work
while pacing in the
office or going outside,
what he impressed on me
is that zone 2 cardio
can be meshed throughout
the daily activities
that I and everybody else
generally have to do.
And this was of great relief
to me because I as many of you
are, I'm extremely busy.
I don't have time to schedule
in more cardio per week,
or at least I don't see
the way I could do that
without reducing the amount
of sleep that I'm getting,
or without reducing the
amount of social connection
that I'm getting with family
and friends, both of which
are extremely important to
our mental health and physical
health.
So the basic tool
here is yes, get
200 minutes per week
minimum of zone 2 cardio.
And notice I said 200 minutes,
not 150 minutes to 200 minutes.
I'm going to set
the higher threshold
of 200 minutes per week
minimum of zone 2 cardio.
But that you don't need
to schedule that as time
on the treadmill.
If you want to, great.
But what was communicated to
me from Dr. Andy Galpin is
that zone 2 cardio is
immensely beneficial,
it's not going to
impede, and in fact, it's
going to improve other
aspects of fitness,
and that it does not have
to impede and it in fact
can improve other
aspects of our daily life
like our ability to engage
socially, our ability
to have a great output at
work in whatever type of work
you do.
So the message is very simple,
get 200 minutes or more
of zone 2 cardio per week.
And the message is also
a very reassuring one
which is that zone 2
cardio can be spread
throughout your
daily activities,
and that if you're
doing enough of it,
you probably don't even have to
count the total amount of zone
2 cardio that you're getting.
If you simply make the
effort to move around
a lot more during
your daily activities
and to mesh that zone 2 cardio
with your daily activities,
you're going to hit
that threshold of 200
minutes per week minimum.
Now, that's a great
message for me
because I'm already doing
the three resistance training
workouts per week.
I'm doing what now
I can just call
the two other cardiovascular
training workouts per week
because now I don't even count
that long Sunday jog or Sunday
hike as exercise.
I just consider that movement
out of doors on the weekend.
And in doing so, it's also
allowed me to really enjoy
that a lot more.
There's something about
considering something
a fitness training program that
shifts it from just recreation
and enjoying life to training.
And I, of course, love training.
I love training in the gym, and
I love training out of doors.
I love running.
I love lifting weights.
I love all sorts of
physical training.
I know many people do, I
know many people don't.
But if one looks
at zone 2 cardio
as just part of
their daily life,
you're far more likely to get
that zone 2 cardio in and all
the benefits that come with it.
And you're also opening up time
for work for social engagements
and to do and pay attention
to other aspects of fitness,
which is what we're
going to talk about next.
The second tool that I've
incorporated into my fitness
regimen and that I believe
can be of great benefit
to frankly everybody is to
start including low repetition,
pure strength work.
Now, some of you may already
be doing low repetition,
pure strength work.
But I believe that
most people don't.
Most people who do
resistance training
are using either
machines, or free weights,
or some combination of
those, or perhaps they're
using body weight.
And they tend to focus on
repetition ranges from about 5
and usually more like
6 repetitions out
to about 10 and
perhaps 15 repetitions.
Now, of course, doing resistance
training and repetition
ranges of 5-15 reps
per set, provided
it's done at
sufficient intensity,
so either to failure or
close to failure, of course,
in good form is
tremendously beneficial.
It can help build strength.
It can enhance hypertrophy.
There is tremendous value to
training in those repetition
ranges.
But when I sat down
with Dr. Andy Galpin
to discuss resistance
training, specifically, he
made it very clear that
at least for some portion
of one's yearly training cycle.
So perhaps eight weeks or
10 weeks, or in the case
that I adopted 12 weeks,
there is tremendous benefit
to training in the 3 to 5
repetition range and maybe even
lower.
So the second tool of
training specifically
for strength in the 3
to 5 repetition range
is something that I started to
incorporate after I sat down
to record that series.
And I'll just tell you
a few of the benefits
that I've experienced,
and then I'll
tell you the specific
protocol that
makes it very easy to do this.
The most obvious benefit to me
was that I got much stronger.
And that that strength
persisted such that
when I went back to using
higher repetition ranges,
so typically I train
with weights or machines
in the 6 to 10 repetition range,
sometimes a little higher,
sometimes a little lower.
But never before
had I specifically
trained in the 3 to
5 repetition range
exclusively for a period
of 10 to 12 weeks.
And when I did that, I, of
course, gained strength.
But that strength
stayed with me such
that when I returned to
higher repetition ranges,
I could use more weight in
good form, and that, of course,
enhanced strength and
hypertrophy further.
In addition, there was another
effect that was at least to me
very unexpected, which was
that my cardiovascular training
improved significantly.
Now, why would this be?
Because typically a
3 to 5 repetition set
does not elevate the
heart rate for long enough
that you would consider it
cardiovascular training.
And of course, the rest
periods between those sets
is pretty long as well.
So even if heart rate goes
up during those heavy sets,
it's going to go down during
those long 3 to 5 minute rest
periods between those sets.
But what I noticed was that my
overall posture and my ability
to maintain
cardiovascular output
while using good running
form or good rowing form
was also vastly improved.
And the logical interpretation
of why that would be
is simply that the
muscles got stronger,
and those same muscles
are being incorporated
into the cardiovascular--
let's call it endurance work
that I'm doing on other days.
And therefore, I can carry out
those cardiovascular training
sessions in better form
for longer periods of time.
I actually felt much stronger
during my cardiovascular
training as I got much stronger
moving these heavier weight
loads for low repetition sets.
And then the third specific
benefit that I noticed
is that when training heavy
for 3 to 5 repetitions per set,
I didn't get sore.
And this to me was
an incredible benefit
because typically when I
train in the 6 repetition
to 15 repetition
range and I take
those sets to failure
or near failure,
I do experience some
soreness the next day.
Ordinarily that soreness
isn't so intense
that it prevents
me from doing any
of the other sorts of
workouts that I do.
And for those of you
that have visited
that foundational
fitness protocol,
you know that I hit each major
and minor muscle group once
per week directly as well
as once per week indirectly.
That's the overall
structure of that program
in order to allow
sufficient recovery
between those resistance
training workouts
to be able to make
continual progress.
Now, by training in this
3 to 5 repetition range
that Dr. Andy
Galpin suggested, I
was able to improve
my strength, improve
my cardiovascular
output, reduce soreness.
I also just felt better overall.
I had a lot more energy after
those workouts than I typically
do after my resistance
training sessions
when I use higher
repetition ranges.
There are just a number
of different things
that made me feel, wow, this
is really a powerful protocol.
And of course, moving
heavier weights in the gym
feels good too.
It feels good to get stronger.
At least there's a positive
feedback loop there for me,
and I think for most people.
And I should also mention
that for those of you that
are averse to doing heavier
resistance training in the 3
to 5 repetition range because
you fear that it will make you
too big or too bulky, training
in the low repetition ranges
is actually more geared
towards increasing strength
and is shifting away somewhat
from increasing hypertrophy
or muscle size.
So that's a great
benefit for those of you
that want to be
strong and also want
to maintain
cardiovascular fitness,
but you don't want
to add muscular size.
And of course, for all of you
that want to add muscular size,
it's well established that
increasing your strength
will allow you then
to return to patterns
of hypertrophy
training that will
allow you to use
heavier weights,
and therefore induce
greater hypertrophy.
So there are oh, so many reasons
to incorporate these strength
training protocols.
So the way that Dr.
Andy Galpin suggested
one do it and was the
way that I did it is he
used this 3 by 5 protocol.
The 3 by 5 protocol is
very straightforward.
It involves doing three to
five exercises per workout.
OK.
So if it's a workout for legs,
it's three to five exercises.
If it's a workout for
some upper body muscle,
it's three to five exercises.
Three to five exercises for
3 to 5 sets per exercise,
3 to 5 repetitions per
set, and 3 to 5 minutes
of rest between each set.
In addition, he
emphasized that one
can do those workouts three
to five times per week.
Although, I'm going
to put an asterisk
next to that last statement
because I found that I couldn't
do the 3 by 5
protocol say for legs
specifically three to
five times per week.
I realize that might be
possible for some people,
but I'm somebody who like
many of you out there,
either doesn't have the time
or doesn't have the recovery
capacity to train my legs
three to five times per week.
Even though I acknowledge
that there are probably
ways to do that would
still allow me to recover,
it just simply starts to impede
into other areas of training.
It starts to impede other areas
of life like work and family
and sleep and all the rest.
So what I did and what
I'm suggesting you try
is for any existing resistance
training that you're doing,
to take a period of 8 or
10 or ideally 12 weeks
and do the vast majority, if not
all of that resistance training
in the lower repetition range
that's designed specifically
to induce strength adaptations.
And to not pay attention
to whether or not
you're hitting that same muscle
group three to five times
per week, rather if you
train your legs once or twice
per week, to simply do all
of the work for your legs
in that 3 to 5 repetition range.
If you train an upper body
muscle or muscle groups,
chest, shoulders, back
once per week or twice
per week to just stay
within that 3 to 5
repetition range
for those work sets.
Warm-ups can include
a few more reps.
And then to adhere
to this three to five
exercises, 3 to 5
sets per exercise,
3 to 5 repetitions per set, and
3 to 5 minutes between sets.
Now, the one exception to
this that I incorporated
was that for very
small muscle groups.
So for instance, the rear
deltoids or for neck work,
or for calf work to not rely
purely on 3 to 5 repetitions
but maybe to work in
a range of anywhere
from 5 to 8 repetitions.
So still fairly low
repetitions but not so low
that it restricts you
to 3 to 5 repetitions.
The reason for that is that I
and I think a lot of people out
there find it hard to
fatigue those smaller muscle
groups adequately with good
form when restricting oneself
to those low repetitions.
However, for big
compound movements
like presses and squats and
deadlifts and glute ham raises
and things of that sort, maybe
even leg extensions and leg
curls, which are isolation
exercises, of course, to really
restrict oneself to those
3 to 5 repetition ranges
that take you to
failure or near failure.
I listed off the benefits of
doing that that I experienced,
and I'm confident
that you will also
experience a lot of benefits.
So just to remind you what
some of those benefits are,
you get stronger,
which feels great.
That occurs within
your weight workouts,
but it also carries over to your
endurance training sessions.
I also noticed
that when returning
to higher repetitions
for resistance training,
so after 12 weeks shifting away
from 3 to 5 repetition ranges
and going back to training
in the 6 to 10 repetition
ranges mainly.
Occasionally up to 12 or 15
but really mainly restricting
to 6 to 10 repetitions that you
can move much heavier weights
in good form, and thereby
induce more hypertrophy
while still also continuing
to gain some strength.
And another benefit was
again reduced soreness
compared to when training
with higher repetition
ranges and more
mental freshness,
I guess the only
way to describe it,
when training in those
lower repetition ranges.
I don't know about
you, but when I
finish a really hard
hour-long resistance training
session done in the 6
to 12 repetition range,
there's a certain
type of mental fatigue
that even if I eat
properly afterwards,
even if I hydrate
properly, that it
tends to sap a bit of my
mental energy later in the day.
But that the training at
the 3 to 5 repetition range
did just the opposite.
It actually enhanced my
focus and my cognition,
my overall levels
of physical energy,
which is great
because it allows you
to do all the other
things that we're required
to do throughout the day.
And by the way,
it will also allow
you to get more of
that zone 2 cardio.
So if you want more details
on the 3 by 5 protocol,
again, that's time stamped
in the relevant episode
on strength and hypertrophy that
we did with Dr. Andy Galpin.
I'll also provide a link to that
specific time stamp in the show
note caption to this episode.
I do want to point out that
you don't just jump right
into heavy sets of
3 to 5 repetitions,
you need to warm up adequately.
For some people that warm-up
will be higher repetition sets,
so say 10 to 12 repetitions
with just the empty bar
or a lightweight.
And then adding a
little bit of weight
and doing 8 repetitions
and maybe 6 repetitions,
and then your work
sets as they're
called of 3 to 5 repetitions.
Or perhaps you're
like me and you
prefer to do low
repetition warm-ups.
So this was also something
that I discussed with Dr. Andy
Galpin and that for me has made
a tremendous positive impact
on all my resistance training,
regardless of whether or not
it is low repetition
or high repetition.
And that's to do a brief
warm set that is somewhere
in the range of 6
to 8 repetitions,
very light just to get
familiar with the movement.
Then to do a second
warm-up set that
includes some load on the bar or
the free weight or the machine.
And then a second warm-up set--
again, this could be
free weights or machines
that incorporates
a bit more load
but still keeps the repetitions
low so in the 4 to 6
repetition range.
And then maybe,
especially if it's
at the beginning of the workout
and my core body temperature
isn't elevated yet,
I'll do a third warm-up.
But that third warm up
which, of course, is
going to be progressively
a little bit heavier
than the first or
second warm-up,
is still going to fall within
the low repetition range
so just 2 to 4 repetitions.
For me, including a
few more warm-up sets
with progressively heavier
weight on each warm
up but still keeping the
total repetition count
low, so somewhere in the
range of 2 to 6 repetitions,
has been very beneficial
for improving my work
output during the so-called
work sets regardless of
whether or not I'm training
in the 3 to 5 repetition range
or whether or not I'm
training in the 6 to 15
repetition range.
I know for some people, this
might be kind of surprising,
how is it that my work sets
are actually higher repetition
than my warm-up sets?
Or put differently,
how and why is it
that my warm-up sets are lower
repetition than my work sets?
And that's because I fall
into this category of people
that tends to fatigue
pretty quickly when
doing resistance training.
So for me, keeping
the repetition count
on any individual
warm up set pretty low
has allowed me to really
improve my strength output
and really improve my
strength and hypertrophy
training when I shift to
the so-called work sets.
So I already listed off a
number of important documented
benefits and benefits
that I've certainly
experienced by incorporating
low repetition,
pure strength work into
my yearly training cycle
for periods of 8 to 12 weeks.
In addition to that, during
my conversation with Dr. Andy
Galpin, he said
something very important
for everyone to
hear and understand.
He said, when you look at the
data on aging and performance,
in particular
muscular performance,
you see some very interesting
patterns within the data.
He said for instance, that
for every year after age 40,
there's a 1% drop in
muscle size that can be
offset by resistance training.
But that if you don't
do resistance training,
that you won't offset.
And during that
series, we also talked
about the minimum
requirement for 6
and probably more
like 10 working sets
per muscle group per week in
order to at least maintain
muscle size, not just age
40 and beyond but even
at younger ages.
OK.
So that's muscle size.
1% decrease per year unless
you do the right thing.
And the right thing is get 6
to 10 working sets per week
in order to offset
that decrease.
And if you train
properly for hypertrophy,
yes, you can still increase
muscle size past age 40.
In addition, he said
that there is a 3% to 5%
reduction per year for every
year past age 40 in strength
and power.
Now, that's a very
important metric
because what it's telling us is
that the drop off in strength
and power is significantly
greater per each year
after age 40 than is the
decrease in muscle size,
telling us that we
have to do something
to offset that decrease
in strength and power.
In addition, he mentioned that
for every year past age 40,
there is an 8% to 10% decrease
in speed and in explosiveness.
And so if one is interested
in maintaining speed
of muscular movement
and explosiveness
of muscular movement,
something that's perhaps
important to a number
of you, one also
has to incorporate training
specifically geared
toward maintaining or improving
speed and explosiveness.
Now, I like many people am
not so interested in speed
and explosiveness, I know
they have their utility,
but I am interested in
maintaining muscle size
over the course of my life,
perhaps even adding some muscle
to a particular muscle groups.
I'm also very interested in at
least maintaining and ideally
even gaining some strength
in certain muscle groups
throughout my entire lifespan.
And that's not just for
performance reasons.
That's also because we know
that maintaining or improving
strength of our muscles
is very important
across the entire
lifespan but especially
in the years spanning
from 40 until death,
which I think for most people
falls somewhere between 50,
60, 70, or ideally, out into
the 80s and 90s or 100, right?
That's what we're all seeking is
to die later in better health.
And in order to do that, we have
to dedicate some very specific
training protocols in order
to maintain or build strength.
So to summarize, in addition to
all the positive reasons to do
dedicated strength
training that I mentioned
before, it's highly recommended
that you do some dedicated
strength training for the
purposes of offsetting
the age-related decline in
strength that occurs again
3% to 5% per year
past age 40, which is
a pretty significant decline.
But the good news is
if you do the 3 to 5
protocol for say
12 weeks per year,
and then you continue
to resistance train
using other repetition ranges
geared towards hypertrophy
and strength or perhaps
even muscular endurance,
the good news is you'll
maintain your strength
and perhaps even
build your strength,
offsetting that natural decrease
that would otherwise occur.
I'd like to take a quick
break and acknowledge
one of our sponsors,
Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens now called AG1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs.
I've been taking Athletic
Greens since 2012,
so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking
Athletic Greens and the reason
I still take Athletic Greens
once or usually twice a day
is that it gets
me the probiotics
that I need for gut health.
Our gut is very important.
It's populated by
gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain, the
immune system, and basically
all the biological
systems of our body
to strongly impact our
immediate and long term health.
And those probiotics
and Athletic Greens
are optimal and vital
for microbiotic health.
In addition, Athletic
Greens contains
a number of adaptogens,
vitamins, and minerals
that make sure that all of my
foundational nutritional needs
are met, and it tastes great.
If you'd like to try
Athletic Greens you can go
to athleticgreens.com/huberman,
and they'll give you five free
travel packs that make it really
easy to mix up Athletic Greens
while you're on the road, in the
car, on the plane, et cetera.
And they'll give you a year's
supply of vitamin D3K2.
Again, that's
athleticgreens.com/huberman
to get the five free travel
packs and the year supply
of vitamin D3K2.
The next tool I'm
about to describe
relates to your
cardiovascular training,
and it's a tool that
can greatly improve
your cardiovascular fitness
with a limited amount of time
commitment.
But that is not
to say it is easy.
What I'm referring to is
the so-called Sugarcane.
If you listened to the
series with Dr. Andy Galpin,
you may recall our discussion
about the Sugarcane,
which is so named after our
friend and expert trainer Kenny
Kane.
And it is a very efficient
yet somewhat brutal
way to increase your
cardiovascular output.
So the Sugarcane is
the type of protocol
that you would incorporate
once in the period of a week
but certainly not every week.
It's the kind of thing that you
might throw in once every two
weeks or once every four
weeks as a replacement
for your other high
intensity interval training.
The Sugarcane involves
selecting some form of exercise
that you can do at
high intensity safely.
That, of course, will
differ between individuals.
For some of you it will
be a stationary bike.
For others of you, it
will be a road bike.
For others of you,
it will be running.
And for others of you,
it will be rowing.
The exact form of
exercise is not important.
What is important
is that you can
generate a lot of intensity.
So you're going to be doing some
sprint like work, although not
all out sprints except
on the final round.
I'll explain where all
this is going in a moment.
But again, you need
to select a movement
that you can do without injuring
yourself while still performing
a movement at high intensity.
So for me that would
be running, for you
it might be something else.
The Sugarcane is pretty
straightforward in structure.
It involves three rounds after
a brief warm-up, of course.
So you're going to do 3
to 5 minutes of jogging
or jumping jacks
or skipping rope,
something to get your
core body temperature
up so that you're prepared to
do the high-intensity work.
And then there are only three
rounds of high-intensity work.
And they go as the
following, in round 1,
you're going to take
2 minutes-- so you'll
need to set a timer
for 2 minutes--
and you're going to go the
maximum distance that you
can in that 2 minutes.
So run the maximum distance that
you can for 2 minutes, or cycle
the maximum distance that
you can for 2 minutes,
or VersaClimber the
maximum distance
that you can for 2 minutes.
Whatever you
select, you're going
to do that as far and
as fast as you can
for the duration of 2 minutes.
So depending on the
movement and depending
on your level of
fitness, that distance
might be 400m, 600m,
800m, et cetera.
Whatever distance you
travel in that 2 minutes,
you are going to mark that
distance down in your mind,
or in your phone, or
on a piece of paper.
And then you're going
to rest 2 minutes.
So 2 minutes of work
then rest 2 minutes.
Then in round 2, you're going
to go the same distance that you
did in round 1, and you're
going to take as much time
as you need to do that
distance as fast as you can.
So if you went 600m in 2
minutes for round 1, in round 2
you're going to
go 600m, and it's
going to take you however
long it takes you.
Chances are if you really did
the best you could in round 1,
you were at maximum output
for the first 2 minutes,
that in round 2 it's
going to take you
longer than 2 minutes to travel
that equivalent distance.
However, there is
the possibility
that it will take you less time.
But for most people, it's
going to take you more time.
So staying with this example of
600m in 2 minutes on round 1,
in round 2, you're
going to go 600m,
let's say it takes
you 2 minutes and 30s.
You then are going to mark
down how long round 2 took you.
So in this case, the example
is 2 minutes and 30s.
Then you're going to
rest another 2 minutes.
And then in round
3, you're going
to go all out again
as fast and as safely
as you can for the same duration
that you did in round 2.
And your goal is to go at least
as far as you went in round 1.
And if there's still
time left, you're
going to continue to go all out
again as fast as you safely can
until the entire
duration is completed.
So it's really just three
rounds with two rest periods
in between round 1 and round 3.
And then I highly recommend
that after round 3,
that you do some sort
of dedicated cooldown.
So instead of just flopping
on to the bench or the floor
or the lawn, that you walk
around slowly until you
recover your breathing.
The reason I like the
sugarcane as a tool
that one implements once
every say two to four weeks
as a replacement for one's
typical high-intensity interval
training is several fold.
First of all, if you
provide the right intensity
in round 1 and
round 2 and round 3,
it is sure to elevate your
heart rate substantially,
and in doing so,
improve your VO2 max,
which is correlated with all
sorts of important metrics
related to health span,
performance, and life span.
Second of all, it gamifies
things a little bit.
It pits you against
yourself in the sense
that if you go out at
maximum speed, again,
performing a movement
that you can safely
perform at maximum speed
in round 1, well, then
you have something to compete
against in round 2 and round 3.
And that makes the
high-intensity interval
training, first of
all, very intense,
but also it makes
it fun in a way that
lets you forget just how
painful the whole thing is.
The next tool to
improve your fitness
is called exercise
snacks and as the name
suggests this is a fun one
and was suggested by Dr. Andy
Galpin as a way to either
enhance or maintain
your fitness depending on
how your core or foundational
fitness program is going.
So when I say core I
don't mean your abs.
I mean whether or not you're
getting your regular cardio
and your regular
resistance training
if you were to add one or
several of these exercise
snacks per week.
It can further improve
things like VO2 max,
muscular endurance, et cetera.
I'll talk about
the specific snacks
that you will be
doing in a moment.
However, as Dr. Andy
Galpin also pointed out,
there are times in
which we happen to not
be following our foundational
fitness program either
because work demands or family
demands or we're traveling.
We're simply not keeping
up with our basic routine.
And under those
conditions, exercise snacks
are a terrific way to maintain
the fitness that you've already
built and developed, and you
don't lose any ground in a week
say where you get
particularly busy.
Now, exercise snacks can take
on a variety of different forms.
But for sake of
simplicity and clarity,
today we're going to divide
them into two major categories.
The first category
are exercise snacks
that are going to
improve or maintain
your cardiovascular fitness,
so your ability to run
or cycle or row some distance
say 12 minutes or longer.
But keep in mind these exercise
snacks are very, very brief.
They don't require that you do
them for 12 minutes or longer.
What they are going to do is
either maintain or enhance
the type of
endurance that allows
you to continue in an activity
for 12 minutes or longer.
The second category
of exercise snack
relates to muscular endurance.
Muscular endurance is a very
important aspect of fitness.
And even though some
people are already
training for muscular
endurance, it's
something that most people are
not doing enough training for.
Muscular endurance
is your ability
say to maintain a wall set
or to maintain a plank,
or to do the maximum
number of push-ups
that you can do in one session.
The sort of drop to the floor
and give me as many push-ups
as you possibly can type of
thing, or as many sit-ups
as you can type of thing.
Muscular endurance
translates to a number
of other aspects of
fitness, and it's something
that we should
all be working on.
And again, many people just
don't make space for it
in their regular routine.
So now we have these two
categories of exercise snacks.
One geared toward
enhancing or maintaining
your cardiovascular
fitness as it translates
to longer duration endurance
activities, so 12 minutes
or longer.
And then the other category
is purely muscular endurance,
which is essentially some
bout of exercise that's
going to be fairly
brief, anywhere
from a minute to 2 minutes but
certainly less than 12 minutes.
OK, so let me give you
an example of an exercise
snack for enhancing your
long-duration endurance,
12 minutes or longer.
And this is the sort
of thing that if you
are going to incorporate
into your routine,
and I highly
recommend that you do,
can essentially be done
any time with no warm-up.
A good example of an
exercise snack of this type
would be to suddenly
stand up from your desk
and to do 100 jumping jacks.
Now, depending on
how fit you are
and how fast you do
those jumping jacks
and how wide and tall you
do those jumping jacks,
meaning are you doing
these little things where
your hands don't actually meet
and your hands like parting
your legs just a
little bit, or are you
doing full jumping jacks
where you're really
jumping and setting
your feet out
as wide as you
comfortably and safely can
and then bring your
hands together,
it could take you anywhere
from 30 seconds to 90 seconds.
OK.
So in the case of
jumping jacks, you
may end up doing
this for 90 seconds.
But the point is to simply
do 100 jumping jacks.
Or if that takes too
long, you could even
do just 25 or 50 jumping jacks.
The point is that it's going
to get you moving your muscles.
It's going to get
your heart rate up.
Even if you're very, very fit if
you're doing these fast enough
and you're doing them
with proper form,
it's going to get
your heart rate up.
And then you're done.
You can sit back
down to your desk
or you can continue to
walk through the airport.
Yes, I've done these
in the airport.
Typically not while walking
toward my gate but at the gate.
But occasionally I'm
feeling lethargic,
or I haven't had the
opportunity to train that day,
and perhaps I won't get
the opportunity to train,
so I'll do something
like 100 jumping jacks
while facing the
window so it feels
a little less awkward facing
people while you're doing them.
And of course, you don't
have to do jumping jacks.
And equally effective
type of exercise snack
is to find a stairwell
and to simply
go up that stairwell
as fast as you safely
can for 20 to 30 seconds.
So perhaps just find the
bottom of a stairwell
and go up that stairwell
as quickly as you can.
And perhaps go down
And just keep doing that
for about 20 to 40 seconds,
and then you're
essentially done.
OK.
You could also opt to
pick some distance away
from your car in
the parking lot,
assuming you're not carrying
any heavy bags or anything,
and simply run to your car.
So 20 to 30 seconds of not
necessarily all out sprinting.
You don't want to
injure yourself.
Because again, this is
done without a warm-up.
These exercise
snacks are designed
to be inserted into your
day and into your week
essentially at random.
You could plan them if you want.
But any time you feel inspired,
or perhaps any time you're
feeling like you
don't want to do one,
you could simply do one
of these exercise snacks.
And of course, doing jumping
jacks, or running to your car,
or taking the stairs
very quickly up and down,
or just up and
then walking down,
for instance, and doing a
few jumping jacks, things
of that sort, of course,
can take on a near infinite
number of different variations.
So if you don't like
any of the variations
that I just presented,
you can easily
come up with something else.
Again, the purpose of
these exercise snacks
is to get your heart rate up.
It's of course, to do this
while not getting injured,
and it is entirely compatible
with an existing exercise
program.
It in no way is going to impede
your performance in strength
or hypertrophy or other
forms of long-form endurance
or high-intensity
interval training, quite
to the contrary.
Everything we know about
these exercise snacks
is that they enhance various
aspects of your physiology
in ways that promote
both recovery
and performance in your
other types of exercise
and your other types
of athletic endeavors.
So no reason to think
that they are going to be
problematic for your training.
But of course, don't
trip, don't fall,
don't undertake a
movement that puts you
into a range of motion that has
hurting your back, your knee,
or any other part of your body.
Start off slowly
and find something
that really works for you.
So these are very easy.
They take very little time.
They're fun to be honest.
And as was discussed in the
conversation with Dr. Andy
Galpin, they're
also very effective.
The second category
of exercise snack
are the exercise snacks that
enhance muscular endurance.
So muscular endurance
is the type of endurance
that allows you to
maintain a fixed position
for some period of time usually
somewhere between 1 and 3
minutes.
But these endurance
bouts are never
going to last 12 or
more minutes, unless you
are exceptionally
evolved in terms
of your muscular
endurance abilities.
What I'm talking about here
are things like planks,
wall sits, maximum number of
push-ups, things of that sort.
And this is an aspect
of fitness that
translates to other
aspects of fitness
in a very important way.
And again, this was covered
in the exercise series
with Dr. Andy Galpin.
I don't want to go
into any of the details
now because it was
all covered there.
It's very easy to look up
because it's time stamped.
But just being brief,
muscular endurance
allows the buildup of more
microvascular supply to muscles
and connective
tissue in a way that
allows delivery and removal
of more nutrients and waste
products.
Now, I realize to the physios
things like nutrients and waste
products is far too
broad a category,
but what we're
talking about here
is the ability to deliver
more fuel and oxygen
and to remove waste
products of muscular effort,
or to be more specific,
neuromuscular effort.
This is a great
thing because it can
help you enhance your
strength training,
enhance your
hypertrophy training,
enhance your long-distance
endurance and your middle
distance and even your
short distance endurance.
And these exercise snacks for
building muscular endurance
are exceedingly easy to do.
And you can even do them
while talking on the phone,
especially if you're
using headphones,
or if you have your
phone on speaker.
A good example of an exercise
snack for muscular endurance
would be a 30 to 60-second
or perhaps longer wall sit.
So remember wall sits?
Wall sits are as
the name suggests
where you put your feet out
some distance from a wall.
You squat down into
a seated position,
but there's no chair
there, and then
you maintain that
seated position,
and that is harder
to do over time.
You could lean back against
the wall a little bit
harder if you wanted to
gain some extra support
and continue.
But the idea here
is that you're going
to go not necessarily
to muscular failure
but to the point where you
can't continue to sit in
that wall sit position.
You could also simply do
this as an air squat down
to the bottom position
where you're comfortable.
And then you don't want
to rest down there,
and you want to maintain some
tension in your quadriceps
and other muscles
of your lower body
so that you're actively
trying to support yourself
in the seated position but
without a seat below you.
That can be done again while
on a speakerphone conversation,
that can be done at
random throughout the day.
You can just decide, OK, I'm
going to do a wall sit now,
and I'm going to time myself.
I'm going to see how
long I can do this for.
Or you could decide
to do a plank.
I've done this while
on a phone call.
Sorry if it was that
I was talking to,
but I've put the
phone on speaker
and just gotten into
a plank position,
and then I'll just have the
conversation in the plank
position.
I don't fight to maintain that
plank position past the point
where I could continue
to have a conversation.
So again, this is
a type of exercise
that one is trying
to incorporate
into their daily routine.
If you wanted to dedicate
a specific amount of time
just to doing these
exercise snacks, you could.
But it's far more
reasonable to assume
that people will incorporate
these into their daily routine
more regularly if
you can incorporate
it truly into the other
aspects your routine like work.
You do this while watching
TV, or listening to a podcast.
One form of muscular
endurance exercise snack
that's really terrific and is a
bit of a challenge, that's fun
is to just simply see how
many push-ups you can do.
And we talked about proper
push-up form during the episode
series with Dr. Andy Galpin, but
here what we're talking about
is chest all the
way to the ground
so it touches the ground, then
pushing up until your arms are
completely straight.
That's one push-up.
And then continuing in
piston-like fashion,
meaning you're not
pausing at the top
and taking a bunch of breaths.
You're not going into a
plank position in other words
but continuing to
do as many push-ups
as you can to see
whether or not you can
enhance that number over time.
And in any case, just
to simply get your body
working to engage the muscles
of your chest, your shoulders,
your triceps, and your
core, et cetera, and to
do that every once in a while.
So instead of needing somebody
to say drop and give me 20,
just see whether or not
at some point, any point
throughout the day, you can
get into a push-up position
and do your maximum
number of push-ups,
and then just mentally note
that number to yourself.
Again, these exercise
snacks serve multiple roles.
They're designed
to get you moving,
to get your heart rate
going, to maintain or enhance
your fitness in other
domains of fitness.
And this is very important
to not take too much time out
of your schedule.
In fact, like zone
2 cardio, right,
being the type of
movement that you're just
going to do a lot throughout
the week carrying groceries,
et cetera, as we
discussed earlier,
these exercise
snacks are designed
to be incorporated
into your daily life.
And I must say that
having started doing these
after recording the series
with Dr. Andy Galpin,
I've noticed two things.
First of all, including
these exercise
snacks at least once a week and
more like three to five times
a week for me, so that's
one exercise snack
done three to five times
per week has definitely
correlated with
improvements in my fitness
in other domains of fitness,
strength, hypertrophy,
long-distance
endurance, et cetera.
Now, I've changed a
number of other things
as well as a consequence of that
series with Dr. Andy Galpin.
So I can't say for sure that
it's the exercise snacks per se
that are causing all
those positive shifts.
I have to imagine that it's
not just the exercise snacks,
but they've become an
important part of my routine
and that relates to
the second point, which
is that the exercise snacks
are to be fun and easy.
And so I really enjoy
them, so much so
that if I don't one
for couple of days,
I start to crave
them a little bit
like the other kind of snack.
The next category of tool
to improve your fitness
relates to breathing
or respiration.
Now breathing and respiration
is an enormous topic
in and of itself.
In fact, I did an entire episode
on breathing and respiration,
and this is a topic that my
laboratory works on extensively
as it relates to anxiety
control and some other aspects
of mental health, as well
as to physical performance.
For today's discussion, I want
to just review a few tools
that one can incorporate
both into workouts
and around workouts
that can greatly
enhance fitness and recovery.
The first one is the
type of respiration tool
that you use between
sets of exercise.
And again here we're talking
about resistance training,
but we could just
as easily be talking
about rest between rounds of
say high-intensity interval
training.
So for instance, between
bouts of sprinting
on the track or the bike or
the treadmill or the rower.
A great pattern of breathing
to incorporate during rest
between sets is
something that I've
talked about before in
other contexts which
is the physiological side.
The physiological side is a
deep Inhale through the nose
to maximally or near
maximally inflate your lungs,
and then a second
very brief inhale,
and it's necessarily brief
because your lungs are already
pretty full, to maximally
inflate your lungs
and to make sure that
any of the little sacs
or the little
alveoli of your lungs
that have collapsed during
the exercise exertion
will reinflate.
And then a long exhale
until lungs empty.
So I'll demonstrate it right now
as I've done many times before.
But if you haven't seen
it or heard it before,
it's two inhales followed
by an extended exhale.
And it goes like this.
[INHALE, EXHALE]
You'll notice that the
inhales were through the nose
and the exhale was
through the mouth.
That's the ideal way to do
it for a number of reasons.
Check out the episode that I
did on respiration physiology
a.k.a. breathing if you want
more details on why that is.
But two inhales through the
nose and a long extended exhale
through the mouth, the so-called
physiological side not named
by me but rather named by
physiologists in the 1930
is as far as we know,
the fastest way to shift
your nervous system from
so-called sympathetic drive
to more parasympathetic
drive, from a state
of greater alertness to
a state of greater calm.
Now, the reason to do this
between sets of resistance
training is that the more
that you can shift yourself
from sympathetic drive to
parasympathetic drive, that
is from alert to calm in
between sets, the more energy
and focus you can devote to
exertion during your work sets.
So one way to do this that's
very convenient and very
effective is to consider
the last repetition
of your set, a physiological
sigh, which is not
to say, OK, I want
to be very clear,
which is not to
say that you should
do the physiological
side during your set.
In fact, I recommend
that you do not do that.
But rather if you're doing
six repetitions of a given
exercise and you, let's
say, fail on the sixth
or you do that sixth repetition
and you're just close
to failure because again your
work set should be to failure
or close to it most of the
time, then set down the weight,
and then you're going to
do the next repetition
as the physiological
sigh, meaning you're not
going to do the movement.
You're going to think of
doing a physiological sigh
as the last repetition
of every set,
not during the last repetition
of the resistance training
movement, OK.
So the physiological
sigh is something
you do at the beginning
of the rest period
immediately following a set.
If you'd rather think
about it that way
because it's more
convenient than thinking
about it as the last rep
of a set, be my guest.
Whatever works for you.
But what you'll quickly
find is that if you
do a physiological sigh
right after completing
your last repetition, you'll
calm down much more quickly,
your heart rate will
come down more quickly,
and you'll recover more
completely in whatever
designated rest period
you've allowed yourself,
whether or not it's
30 seconds, which
would be very short frankly, or
it's a 5-minute period of rest
between sets.
If you do one truly, just
one physiological sigh
at the beginning
of the rest period,
you are going to effectively
shift your nervous system
in the direction you want it to
go during those rest periods.
And of course, if you're
training hard during your work
sets you run zero
risk whatsoever
of feeling so calm
that you don't feel
motivated to do your next set.
I promise you that it will
allow you to relax more
at the beginning
of the rest period
than you ordinarily would, to
shift into a state of rest.
There are differing opinions
about whether or not
you should walk around or stay
still during your rest periods.
I like to walk around a
bit and stay standing.
I'm not one of these
people that collapses
into a C-shape on the
bench in between sets.
I like to stand up and breathe
normally and walk around, drink
a little water, et cetera.
In any case, doing
a physiological side
the beginning of
each rest interval
between work sets of
resistance training
is a very effective
way to enhance
your focus and your output
during your work sets.
Now, the last respiration
tool to improve your fitness
is again a tool gleaned from
the discussion with Dr. Andy
Galpin, and that's
to include a 3 to 5
minute period at the end
of every single workout.
So it doesn't matter if
it's high-intensity interval
training, or it's
resistance training,
or it's a long run of some sort,
at the end of every workout,
to take 3 to 5 minutes, so
you'll want to set a timer,
and to do some form of
parasympathetic, that
is calming promoting
breathing in order
to shift your nervous system
from a state of heightened
alertness and output
into a state of recovery.
Because as you all
well know by now,
you get fitter not
during your workouts
but rather after your
workouts, in between workouts.
So you stimulate the
adaptation during a workout,
but you get the adaptation,
you get the actual improvement
in between workouts.
And a common mistake that
many people make, and I
made this mistake for years,
was to finish a great workout,
and then you're
texting on your phone,
or you're talking on the
phone, or you're driving home.
It's certainly not as intense as
the workout that you just did.
Maybe you're even feeling really
calm from a nice long jog,
or you had a particularly
good workout that day
and you're feeling really happy.
So you're enjoying the
high, so to speak, well,
when you do 3 to 5 minutes
of what's often called down
regulation breathing
after a workout,
it allows you to
recover and to induce
the adaptation that
you've been after, the one
that you actually trained
for much more quickly.
I can't tell you
how many people I
know who start to incorporate
this into their workouts,
find that they recover far
better from their workouts,
which might seem a
little bit surprising.
Why would it be that just 3
to 5 minutes of some activity
would enhance recovery
to such a great degree?
And that's because
typically people
don't bookend their workouts.
They finish their workouts,
and of course, they're
not continuing to
lift weights or run.
But they move about
their day in their life
even if it's preparing a meal in
a way that the level of stress,
and therefore, stress
hormones, things like cortisol,
adrenaline, things
that by the way
are excellent to elevate
during a workout, things
like inflammatory
markers, which by the way,
are great to enhance
during a workout.
That actually happens
You have a massive increase
in inflammatory markers, which
might seem bad, but
all of those things
are enhancing the adaptation
that you're seeking.
But as soon as
those workouts end,
you want to shift
into recovery mode.
And this 3 to 5 minutes of
down regulation breathing
is a terrific way to do that.
There are a couple of
different patterns of breathing
that will work best, but all
of them emphasize exhales.
OK.
I want to repeat that, all
of them emphasize exhales.
So for instance, you
could just choose
slow, deliberate breathing.
How does that emphasize exhales?
Well, ordinarily when we
breathe, we inhale actively
and we exhale passively.
Whenever we deliberately
breathe more slowly,
we are actively exhaling.
OK, so active exhales really
promote the calming response
in brain and body.
The other thing you could do
which many people are now doing
is to do a repeated round
of physiological sighs.
So the double inhale
through the nose,
long exhale through the mouth
but repeated for say 3 minutes.
That's another version.
The other thing you could do is
simply to notice your exhales
and to emphasize your exhales,
make them longer and more
vigorous than your inhales.
Now, you don't want to turn this
into a breathwork session where
you're--
[INHALE,EXHALE]
--you're doing it Pranayama
or Kundalini breathing
or something of that sort.
The idea is to calm down.
So any time you're
extending your exhales,
you're actively
exhaling, you're trying
to slow your breathing
down overall,
you're going to shift yourself
in the right direction.
So rather than complicate
this type of tool,
the best thing you can do is
just focus on those exhales,
slow your breathing overall,
use physiological sighs
if you want, or simply
sit in your vehicle,
or if you have to
drive home while doing
this extended exhale
type of down regulation.
Ideally you would take
a couple of minutes
and just shift your whole
system by not driving, closing
your eyes and just sitting in
your car stationary, of course,
don't drive with your eyes
closed, or bike with your eyes
closed.
Just simply calm down,
extend your exhales
and shift from the
workout to the recovery
mode, which is where the
progress is going to arrive.
I'd like to take a quick break
and acknowledge our sponsor
InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA
to help you better
understand your body
and help you meet
your health goals.
I'm a big believer in getting
regular blood work done
for the simple reason that
many of the factors that
impact your immediate
and long-term health
can only be analyzed from
a quality blood test.
However, with a lot of
blood tests out there,
you get information back about
blood lipids, about hormones,
and so on, but you
don't know what
to do with that information.
With InsideTracker they
have a personalized platform
that makes it very easy to
understand your data, that
is to understand
what those lipids,
what those hormone
levels, et cetera
mean and behavioral supplement,
nutrition and other protocols
to adjust those
numbers to bring them
into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and
long-term health.
InsideTracker's ultimate
plan now includes measures
of both ApoB and
of insulin, which
are key indicators of
cardiovascular health
and energy regulation.
If you'd like to
try InsideTracker,
you can visit
insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off any of
InsideTracker plans.
Again, that's
insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
The next tool is to
improve your fitness are
psychological tools,
and they're really
geared toward enhancing your
focus during your workout
and separating or
segmenting your workouts
from the other
parts of your day.
Now, of course,
workouts are naturally
segmented from the
other parts of your day,
unless you're running
around all day long,
or you're lifting weights or
other heavy objects all day
long.
But one of the more
attractive tools
that was presented during
the series with Dr. Galpin
that I adopted and found
to be really effective
is this concept of the line.
The line is this concept that
you have a physical location,
say at the entrance to a gym
or at the start of your run
or your bike or maybe it's
around the stationary exercise
device that you use for which
once you cross that line,
you are all about business.
OK.
You're not socializing
or at least not too much.
You don't want to
be rude to people,
but you're really
focused on your workout.
So this is especially
effective on days
when you're a little
bit distracted,
or you didn't sleep that
well the night before,
or maybe you've got something
going on in your mind,
or you're in an
argument, or you're
excited about something else.
But if you care about
your fitness, which
I hope everyone does, and
your goal during any workout
is to stimulate
a particular type
of physiological adaptation
strength, hypertrophy,
long-distance
endurance, et cetera,
and you also don't want to
get injured so that you can
continue to train
for your entire life
as regularly as possible,
the concept of the line
is fantastic
because what it does
is it forces you
to compartmentalize
the portion of your lesson
that comes before the workout
and after the workout and also
to really enjoy your workouts.
This is something that's
not often discussed,
but nowadays with the
advent of smartphones,
there's a lot of infiltration
of other types of communication
and information while one is
supposed to be exercising.
And so our life has become
far less compartmentalized
than it used to be before
the advent of smartphones.
Now, of course,
smartphones are wonderful.
They provide all sorts of
wonderful tools and benefits,
and of course, I use one.
And I'll talk about
how to incorporate
the smartphone in
a very specific way
to enhance your workouts
in just a moment.
But the idea of a line
is you pick a location.
It can change with each
workout, but ideally it
would be at the threshold of
where the physical location
to the workout begins.
And once you cross that
line, you are all business.
You are taking care of business.
Which is not to say that you
can't enjoy your workouts.
In fact, you absolutely should.
One of the best pieces of advice
that I ever got about fitness
was given to me when
I was a teenager
and I started lifting weights.
And the person who was teaching
me how to do that said,
one of the best
things that you can do
and you absolutely should do
for your fitness now and forever
is to learn to
enjoy training hard.
And that really stuck with me.
I really do enjoy
training hard, but that
was something that I
learned how to do over time.
I took on the mentality
that I'm here by choice,
I'm here for my own
good and my own fitness
to enhance my life so I'm
going to enjoy training hard,
I'm going to enjoy
training effectively.
And of course, there are days
when I train a little less hard
or I back off quite a bit.
I even take rest
periods of a week
every once in a while,
every say 12 to 16 weeks
I'll take a week off and just
do some activities like hiking
and things of that sort.
I talk to all about
extended layoffs,
meaning a layoff of more than
two days during the episode
that I did by myself, which is
the Optimal Fitness protocols
episode.
But in any case, learning to
train hard and enjoy training
hard and really making
the workout something that
is separate from the
rest of your life
is one of the most
gratifying things
that you can do to enhance
your overall fitness because it
really teaches you
how to designate
your mind and your body toward
this one specific set of goals
while you are there
and to really enjoy
the process because
fitness can be a truly
enjoyable process even when
you are exerting yourself,
especially hard.
And for you
masochists out there,
it can be, especially
because you're training hard
that it feels so good.
In any event, the key is to
set some sort of boundary
and know that when you
cross into that boundary,
you're training.
And when you cross
out of that boundary,
you're done training,
which also lends itself
to more adequate recovery
and the decompression type
breathing exercises that
we talked about before.
I'm not going to tell
you whether or not
you need to do the
down regulation
breathing at the end of
your workout within the line
or after you cross the line.
That's up to you.
I don't think one needs
to get that specific.
Now, another tool that's
wonderfully effective
not just for your workouts
but for all areas of your life
is if you are going to bring
a smartphone to your workouts,
to set some boundaries
around what you're
going to listen to and
do with that smartphone
during your workouts.
I see people texting.
I see people doing selfies.
I see people having phone calls.
I see people, I presume,
listening to music or podcasts.
Look, I am not the smartphone
police nor are you,
and everyone has a right to
use their smartphone in the way
that they choose
as best for them
in order to distract
themselves or focus themselves
or enrich their life.
Look, it's a free world,
of course, more for some
than for others,
but you can do what
you want with your smartphone.
However, if your goal is
to improve your fitness,
one of the more powerful things
you can do with your smartphone
is to decide before you cross
the line into your workout what
you're going to listen to or
do with that phone or not.
So for me, I like to
designate a playlist of music
for that particular
workout, and then
I just stick to that playlist.
I might repeat songs
that I like a lot,
or if someone talks to me
while the music is playing,
I might go back and restart
a song if they distracted me,
that sort of thing.
Although, I do my best to not
get into too much social chit
chat during workouts,
but I'm friendly,
and it's nice when people
come over and say hello.
I sometimes work out with
other people in which case
I don't use headphones,
I don't use a smartphone.
But setting a playlist or two,
designating a podcast or two,
designating an audiobook
or two, whatever
it is that you're going to
listen to really decide what
that's going to be before
you do your workout.
And the reason I say this is
that I observe a lot of people,
and frankly, I've observed
myself under conditions where
I'm suddenly in a
text communication,
or I'm bouncing between
albums or between podcasts
or between whatever it is
on the phone to the point
where rest intervals aren't
being controlled well,
to the point where
focus during sets
becomes harder to achieve
at the beginning of a set
because in between sets I was
focused on a conversation not
on training.
I'm a big believer in
making your exercise fun,
making it accessible,
meaning not so
expensive or
geographically difficult
to achieve that you don't do it
or that it starts to interfere
with other areas of life.
This is really important.
You want fitness to be blended
with the rest of your life,
but you don't want it so blended
with the rest of your life
that the rest of your life
starts to impede your efforts.
Or and this happens quite
often for a lot of people
that workouts start to
take an hour and a half,
two hours when they could easily
be completed in 45 minutes
to an hour if you were just
more efficient with your time.
And of course, you don't
need me to tell you this,
but smartphones can be one of
the major bleeds on our focus
and efficiency.
In fact, it can cause
you to hemorrhage
focus and efficiency.
So what I'm
suggesting here is not
throwing away your smartphone,
although, some people
do benefit from just
leaving it in the car
or at home when
they are training.
But rather to designate
podcasts, books, music
playlists for that
particular workout
and to just stick to those for
the duration of your workout.
And once you cross
into the line,
that's what you're listening
to and only that or nothing.
And of course, once you
cross back over the line
as you finish your
workout, you can
decide to continue to
listen to the podcast,
or continue to listen to the
audiobook, or to the music.
That's up to you.
Although, I highly
recommend that you do
incorporate that
downregulation period
of 3 to 5 minutes minimum.
The last category of tools
to improve your fitness
come from the discussions about
nutrition and supplementation
and recovery in the series
with Dr. Andy Galpin.
Now, the list of tools
I'm about to describe
is not exhaustive,
meaning it doesn't even
begin to come close to
the total number of tools
that one could glean from the
discussion about nutrition
and supplementation
that I had with Dr. Andy
Galpin on this podcast, but
they are the major ones that
are definitely worth knowing.
And those include supplementing
with omega 3 fatty acids.
Now, omega 3 fatty acids
are found of course
in foods, things like
fatty fish and krill,
of all things, certain
forms of algae, et cetera.
But most people do not get
enough of so-called EPA form
of omega 3s.
And for that reason, I
and many other people
choose to supplement with
a minimum of 1 gram per day
and in some cases as
high as 2 grams per day
of omega 3s in supplement form.
So typically one would
get to 1 to 2 grams
of EPA by supplementing
their nutrition, their diet,
that is, with fish oil
capsules or liquid fish oil.
There are many different
sources of these.
That was discussed
in an episode that I
did with Dr. Rhonda Patrick.
I find that it's
most cost efficient
to get that 1 to 2 grams of
EPAs from liquid fish oil
despite what you might
see on the internet.
I don't have any
relationship whatsoever
to a liquid fish oil company.
You just want to make sure that
you go with a reputable brand.
I like the ones
that are flavored
with lemon so that it offsets
the taste of fish oil,
and I'll take a tablespoon
or two of that per day.
And if I'm traveling
and even if I'm not
I will often use
fish oil capsules,
and there are a variety of
different sources of those
as well.
Getting sufficient
amounts of omega 3
has been shown to be
important for mood.
So as a way to offset
depression but also
for enhancing overall
mood that probably
relates to the omega 3s
effect on neurotransmission,
not just for neuromodulators
like serotonin and dopamine
but for all neurotransmission.
And neurotransmission,
of course,
is essential for
neuromuscular performance.
And the omega 3s
have been implicated
in reducing the
inflammation response,
cardiovascular
health, et cetera.
I realized that there is
some debate about omega 3s,
but when I look at the bulk of
literature about the omega 3s,
it's very clear
to me that getting
1 to 2 grams of EPA
form of omega 3 per day
is the right thing for me to do.
And many others
find that as well.
The second tool to
enhance your fitness
under this category of
nutrition and supplementation
is creatine.
Now, again, creatine is not
just found in supplement form.
It's also found, of course, in
foods, in particular red meat.
However, the amount
of red meat that one
would have to eat in order
to get the amount of creatine
that one would start to see
a real performance enhancing
effect is just far too high.
You'd be ingesting far too much
of other things in red meat
that you wouldn't
want that much of.
And for that reason, I
and many other people
will take creatine daily.
We now know there's no need
to so-called load creatinine
in the old days as it were.
So old days, by the way,
meaning mid '90s and 2000s,
we were all told that
we had to load creatine,
we had to take high-dose
creatine for four or five days
and then you could back
off to a maintenance dose.
Now it's very clear you can just
take a daily dose of creatine.
And that it really
doesn't matter
when you take that creatine.
You can take it post-workout
as many people do.
You can take it preworkout.
It really doesn't
seem to matter.
I happen to take it postworkout
just as a matter of habit.
But again, you can take
it any time of day.
Now, the point I want
to make about creatine
is one that's a bit different
than the other discussions
out there.
I have no issue
with the majority
of what's discussed
about creatine out there,
for instance, that
creatine monohydrate
is the most effective form.
Fortunately,
creatine monohydrate
is also the least
expensive form of creatine
that's sold out there.
I see no evidence whatsoever
that the other forms
of creatine are superior
to creatine monohydrate.
But what you'll usually
hear is that taking
5 grams of creatine monohydrate
per day is ideal for everybody.
And that advice is
simply not well-informed
by the scientific literature.
If you are a larger person,
so for instance I weigh 100kg
so that's about 220
pounds, well, it
turns out if you look
at the literature
on creatine and
athletic performance,
and if you look
at the literature
on creatine and
cognitive performance,
because as some of
you already know,
creatine is a fuel or the
phosphocreatine system
is a fuel system for
the brain as well.
And if you look at the
studies on creatine,
they almost always gauge
the amount of creatine
to give an individual
based on their body weight.
So you don't have to get
really specific about this,
but if you weigh, say,
185 pounds to 250 pounds,
you can get away with
and probably should
be taking 10 grams or
so of creatine per day,
which is what I do.
Whereas if you weigh less
than that, 5 grams or maybe
even 3 grams is sufficient.
Now, I discussed this with Dr.
Andy Galpin during that series,
and one of the things
that I've started
to do since the
closure of that series
is to take more
creatine per day.
So now I'm taking
10, sometimes even
as much as 15 grams
per day of creatine.
Again, this is powdered
creatine monohydrate.
My stomach tolerates
it very well,
but frankly, I don't
tend to get stomach aches
or gastric distress from
pretty much anything,
unless it's some form
of food poisoning, which
is exceedingly rare for me.
So some people out there
find that creatine really
disrupts their gut, and they
need to take it with food
or they really need
to slowly and increase
the amount of creatine that
they're taking each day.
I find that I can put 10
even 15 grams of creatine
into a whey protein
shake or into some water
with a little bit
of lemon juice,
just to make it taste a little
less chalky, drink that,
and I don't have any
gastric distress from that.
So you'll need to find
what works for you.
But the point here is if
you're going to take creatine,
you don't just want
to quote unquote,
"take creatine one
scoop per day."
You really want to adjust
the amount of creatine
that you're ingesting
according to your body weight.
And I would give you a very
specific formula of x grams
of creatine per kilogram
or pound of body weight,
but believe it or not, no
such specific recommendation
has ever been published in
the scientific literature
or at least I couldn't find
it in a way that's consistent
with all the other
papers, meaning
you see a lot of variation.
So what I'm talking about here
is if you weigh 185 pounds
or so, OK, plus or minus 5
pounds out to about 250 pounds,
10 to 15g of creatine
per day is probably
more appropriate for
you than is 5 grams,
meaning it's going to be
more effective for enhancing
physical performance.
And perhaps again, perhaps even
cognitive performance as well.
And if you're somebody
who weighs 180 pounds down
to say 130 pounds, 5
grams of creatine per day
is probably sufficient.
The point here is if you
are taking creatine, again,
not everyone has
to take creatine.
There's no law that says that
you have to take creatine.
Some people don't like it.
I know some people
fear it's going
to make their hair fall out.
We already talked about
that in previous episodes
and the lack of data
to support that idea.
But I realize some
people steer away
from creatine for
whatever reason.
But if you decide that taking
creatine is right for you,
adjust the total
amount of creatine
that you take according
to your body weight.
The next supplementation based
tool for enhancing your fitness
is a Rhodiola rosea.
Now, this very esoteric
sounding supplement
is one that I learned about,
both from Dr. Lane Norton when
he was a guest on this
podcast, expert in nutrition
and frankly training as it
relates to resistance training,
and from Dr. Andy Galpin.
Rhodiola rosea is
a supplement that's
gaining increasing attention
because it is what's
called a cortisol modulator.
It does not necessarily
suppress cortisol.
It does not increase cortisol.
It's a cortisol modulator.
And frankly, the
mechanism by which
Rhodiola rosea
modulates cortisol
is still under investigation.
I hope to do an episode
about it in the future
or at least make it
part of an episode
because the hypothesized
mechanism that's
starting to emerge is really
interesting as it relates
to neurons in the brain that
control the stress response
and glands in the body
like the adrenals that
control the stress response
and that secrete cortisol.
Regardless, there's a
growing body of research
that has explored Rhodiola
rosea supplementation and one's
subjective perception
of fatigue or output
during high-intensity
training of various kinds,
both resistance training as well
as running and endurance type
training.
So I started taking Rhodiola
rosea about six months ago
in response to conversations
that I had again with Dr. Lane
Norton and with Dr.
Andy Galpin, and it's
a supplement that I take
before high-intensity workouts.
So I don't take it before a
run because frankly my runs are
either very long
and slow, or they're
very brief like a high-intensity
interval training session.
And I find those to be
pretty easy to recover from
even though they
are very intense.
I might take a Rhodiola
rosea supplement
before doing a 30-minute
hill run that's very intense.
But typically, I only take
it about 10 to 15 minutes
before any sort of
high-intensity resistance
training session,
in particular my leg
day which falls on day 2
of my exercise protocol,
or the torso day, or the
small body parts day.
Again, here I'm
referencing the way
that I train across the week,
and you can find that training
protocol as a downloadable
completely zero-cost
if you like.
But I realize other people
are using different body
part splits and different
combinations of resistance
training and endurance training.
The reason I mentioned
Rhodiola rosea in this episode
is that I realized that while
some people might not yet
be supplementing omega 3s,
they might not be supplementing
creatine, there are many
of you who are already
doing those things, and you're
looking for additional tools
to give you an edge.
So again, the Rhodiola
rosea would not
fall into the category of
foundational supplements.
Certainly, get your nutrition
right, get your sleep right,
get your sunlight.
All the basics first
please before even
thinking about any supplements.
However, once you get into
the category of supplements
that can enhance
fitness, Rhodiola rosea
does seem to have
some good research
to support it in
the context of lots
of different forms of
high-intensity exercise.
Now, I can't tell you whether
or not it's purely subjective
or whether or not it's
objective and subjective,
but my experience has been
that when I take Rhodiola rosea
I definitely notice
that I can exert myself
harder without feeling
like I'm bringing myself
to the brink of fatigue
either during the exertion
or afterwards.
In other words,
I feel like I can
do more work without
feeling so exhausted,
and I feel as if I'm
recovering from my workouts
more quickly, in
particular across the day
after my workouts.
In fact, if I had to cite one
specific subjective effect
that I've experienced
from taking Rhodiola rosea
before very high-intensity
workouts is that prior
to taking it, I would
often find that 3 or 4
hours after the
workout having eaten
a good meal, taking a shower,
et cetera, and I was tired.
I'd have a real dip in energy.
But now I notice that
I have a lot of energy
throughout the day even after
these very high-intensity
sessions in the early
part of the day.
And frankly, I haven't
changed anything else
about my supplementation
or my nutrition, at least
nothing major.
So I personally am
going to continue
to take Rhodiola rosea before
these high-intensity workouts.
So for me, that's about two
or three times per week.
However, if I forgot
to take Rhodiola rosea
before a workout,
I have no reason
to think that workout
would go much worse.
This is a supplement that is
designed to give you an edge
to be able to exert
more focus and intensity
during your workouts with
less perceived exertion
and to enhance your recovery.
The typical dosage
of Rhodiola rosea
that you'll find
in most supplements
is 100 to 200 milligrams.
And of course, any time you're
going to take a new supplement,
you would be wise to figure
out the lowest effective dose
from that supplement.
That's just logic, right?
Why spend more money
taking more of something
that you don't need more
of if you could get away
with taking less of it,
and it's just as effective
maybe even more effective?
So I typically will take
100 to 200 milligrams
of Rhodiola rosea about 10 to
20 minutes before a workout.
However, I've taken as
little as 100 milligrams
on a consistent basis, and
frankly, I don't really
experience much difference
whether I take 100mg
or I take 200 milligrams
before a workout,
so lately I've just defaulted
to taking 100 milligrams
of Rhodiola rosea before
any high-intensity workout.
Now, the final tool
that I want to review
for improving your fitness comes
from the category of nutrition.
I've done lots of
episodes about nutrition
already on this podcast.
We've done episodes about
intermittent fasting
I did a long interview
episode with Dr. Lane Norton
where we discussed all the
ins and outs of nutrition
as it relates to fat
loss, muscle gain, fitness
in general,
lifestyle in general.
So check out that episode where
you will learn his philosophy
on nutrition, which frankly
is the one that I largely
subscribe to.
And of course, obeys the laws
of thermodynamics, calories
in, calories out being
fundamentally important.
But also gets into all sorts
of details about which sources
of protein are most
effective and bioavailable,
how much protein you can
incorporate into your muscles
after training, et
cetera, all of that
is included in that episode.
With that said, the series on
exercise with Dr. Andy Galpin
also included an
episode on nutrition.
And while having the
discussion for that episode
and then listening to
that episode again,
I realized that while certainly
I've gotten a number of things
right about my nutrition
across the years,
there are a few areas where
I could probably do better
without much effort in
ways that could really
enhance my fitness.
And the thing that
I'm referring to
is that for me my first
meal of the day laying
somewhere around 11:00
AM maybe 12:00 noon.
Sometimes I'll eat
an earlier breakfast,
but most typically I hydrate,
caffeinate, and train in
the morning, and then I eat
some time around 11:00 or 12:00.
And then I eat my
last meal of the day
sometime around 8:30 or 9:00.
And as some of you already know,
I tend to organize my meals,
such that meals during
the early part of the day
tend to lean more toward protein
and fibrous carbohydrates,
so things like meat and salad,
or chicken and salad, fish
and salad, and maybe a
little bit of starch.
And the meals that I
eat later in the day
tend to be more starch focused
and more vegetable focused
or things like pasta, rice,
et cetera, later in the day
because it helps me sleep.
And the architecture
of all that is really
about energy and focus.
I find I can focus a bit
better and I have more energy
throughout the day when I have
my first meal at around 11:00
or 12:00, and I keep the
total amount of carbohydrates
that I ingest during
the day moderate.
Not low but moderate.
Now, there is an
exception to that,
which is if I do a
high-intensity resistance
training session
early in the morning
say train legs or train torso
or even small body parts early
in the morning, then I make
sure to incorporate more starchy
carbohydrates and some
fruit, some simple sugars
as well into the
first meal of the day
so that I can
replenish the glycogen
that I depleted during those
high-intensity resistance
training sessions.
However, after talking
to Dr. Andy Galpin,
I realized that I really
shouldn't worry about or be
afraid of eating
something before training
if I'm really hungry
in the morning.
So what I'm
referring to here are
the times in which I wake
up and I want to train,
but I personally like to
train fasted and caffeinated.
OK.
Yes, I do recommend that people
delay their caffeine intake
90 to 120 minutes after
waking if and only
if you have trouble
with an afternoon
crash, real fatigue
in the afternoon, then
it makes sense to
delay your caffeine 90
to 120 minutes after waking.
However, the
exception to that is
that if I'm going to
train early in the day,
I do ingest water to hydrate
as well as electrolytes
and caffeine prior to training.
And sometimes that means
I'm drinking caffeine
within 30 minutes or
60 minutes of waking.
I've tried to be clear about
this in previous episodes,
but I think a number
of people have
come to think that I
always delay my caffeine
intake 90 to 120
minutes after waking,
and that's simply not the case.
If I'm going to train,
in particular if I'm
going to do
high-intensity resistance
training or a long run, I will
ingest caffeine sooner than
90 to 120 minutes after waking.
And in addition to
that, yes, I tend
to eat my first meal around
11:00 AM maybe 12:00 noon.
But if I wake up
and I'm very hungry,
I will eat a small meal
that includes typically
some protein and some fat,
so some Brazil nuts, maybe
a couple of scoops
of whey protein
would be typical for
me, or maybe even
a little bit of oatmeal,
some whey protein,
not a lot of food in my gut.
But after talking to
Dr. Andy Galpin, what
I learned was for some people
training fasted feels best.
I would consider myself
one of those people.
You may be somebody in
that category as well,
or you might be
somebody who really
feels as if you run
best, you resistance
train best when you've eaten say
90 minutes or a couple of hours
before you do that.
There are basically
no specific rules
as it relates to whether or not
you train fasted or train fed
except in what you can handle
in terms of gastric distress.
So you want to make food
choices according to that
and try and avoid, of
course, gastric distress.
But basically the change that
I've made is if I wake up
and I'm hungry, I'll
eat a small meal,
or if I want to work
out in the afternoon
or I have to work
and I have lunch at say,
12:00 or 12:30 or 11:00 AM
and the only opportunity
that I have to train
is 1:00 PM or even 12:30,
I will go ahead and train.
And that's a new thing for me.
Typically, I try
to keep my meals
at least three to four hours
prior to any training bout.
And of course, if you're
sleeping all night,
you're not eating, and then if
you wake up and you don't eat
and you train in the
morning, that's certainly
longer than three or four
hours unless you're sleeping
very, very little frankly.
So essentially what I'm
saying is figure out
what works best for you.
Do you prefer to
train fasted or fed?
For some of you, you might
prefer fasted before cardio
and fed before
resistance training.
For some of you, it might
be fasted is always best.
Again, I put myself
in that category.
For some of you, it might
be fed is always best.
Again, this is
highly individual.
And that's another point
that I'm trying to make here,
which is Dr. Galpin really
impressed upon me that there
is no hard and fast rule
about training fasted or fed.
And, this is the second point,
that having some flexibility
in whether or not you
can train fasted or fed
allows you to incorporate
your fitness training
sessions more readily
into a shifting schedule.
And that's a really
overarching theme of everything
we've been discussing
today, which is yes,
it's wonderful and important
to have a core fitness
program, something that
you're really striving
to do each and every week.
And for me, that's three
sessions of cardio,
three resistance
training sessions,
and a day where I'm doing
thermal stress training, which
is just fancy language for
deliberate cold and deliberate
heat exposure.
However, real life happens,
travel, work, illness,
family, all those
sorts of things
that can impinge on
an exercise schedule
and make it less likely that one
would complete their workouts.
So today we've been
discussing tools
to improve your fitness which
are brief, easy to incorporate,
scientifically
supported, and that
are shown to improve the various
sorts of exercise adaptations
and recovery that will
allow you to get the most
progress from your schedule.
So while the tools
that we discussed today
relate to breathing,
they relate to nutrition,
they relate to
supplementation, they
relate to specific set and
rep patterns and cadences
and rest periods,
et cetera, all of
those specific recommendations
are within a larger container
that I hope has become clear,
which is the best tools
to improve your fitness are
the tools that are, of course,
are going to be
effective in improving
your cardiovascular and strength
and hypertrophy training,
et cetera, whatever it
is that your goals are,
but also tools that are going to
make it easier and more likely
that you are going to engage
in your fitness program
with enthusiasm, with
effort, and with focus.
And as with any episode
of this podcast,
I covered a lot of
information, and there
are a lot of different tools
that one could incorporate.
By no means do you need
to incorporate them all.
Although, if you choose
to, that's wonderful.
Just even incorporating
one or two of them,
say incorporating this notion
of the line and the exercise
snacks, or adjusting
your level of flexibility
as to whether or not you train
fasted or fed and the line,
or trying a 12-week cycle of
purely training for strength
when you do your
resistance training.
But whether or not you pick
one tool or all the tools
or somewhere in
between, the key thing
is to actually implement them.
And I like to think that
during today's discussion
provided a number
of tools, again,
largely gleaned from the episode
series with Dr. Andy Galpin.
And again, if you
haven't seen that series,
that's linked in the
show note captions.
Those episodes are long.
There are six of them, but they
are a wealth of information
of every aspect of fitness.
During today's episode,
we're really just talking
about the things
that you can and I
do believe should bring to your
existing fitness program that
can really make a
positive difference
without a lot of effort.
Thank you for joining me
for today's discussion
all about tools to
improve your fitness.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to
our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero-cost
way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify
and Apple, you
can leave us up to
a 5-star review.
If you have questions
for me or comments
about the podcast
or guests that you'd
like me to include on
the Huberman Lab podcast,
please put those in the
comments section on YouTube.
I do read all the comments.
Please also check
out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
During today's episode and
on many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast
we discussed supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive tremendous
benefit from them from things
like enhancing sleep,
hormone support, and focus.
The Huberman Lab podcast is
partnered with Momentous.
If you'd like to see the
supplements discussed
on the Huberman Lab podcast,
please go to livemomentous
spelled O-U-S, so
livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you're not already
following me on social media,
it is Huberman Lab on all
social media platforms.
So that's Instagram, Facebook,
Twitter, and LinkedIn.
And on all of those
platforms I cover
science and science-based
tools, some of which
overlaps with the content
of the Huberman Lab podcast
but much of which is
distinct from the content
on the Huberman Lab podcast.
So again, it's Huberman Lab
on all social media platforms.
If you haven't already
subscribed to the Huberman Lab
podcast Neural
Network newsletter,
this is a completely
zero-cost newsletter.
Comes out about once a
month, and it includes
podcast summaries and toolkits.
Toolkits are short PDFs
that, for instance, describe
a tool kit for sleep,
a tool kit for learning
and neuroplasticity, a toolkit
for fitness, and on and on.
To sign up for the Neural
Network newsletter,
you simply go to
hubermanlab.com.
Go to the menu.
Scroll down to newsletter
and provide your email.
We do not share your
email with anybody.
And again, the Neural
Network newsletter
is completely zero cost.
Thank you once again for joining
me for today's discussion
all about tools to
improve your fitness.
And last but
certainly not least,
thank you for your
interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]